[Music]
don't like you won't see donning any Sex
in the City couture anytime soon skin
katrell oh sure
samantha jones is good and good and she
made that very clear after her Piers
Morgan interview went viral and now
there are more bombshells from Kim as
she admits she and the girls were never
real-life soul mates we've never been
friends
we've been colleagues and in some ways
it's a very healthy place to be
Kim shattering the illusion once and for
all the women of Sex in the City were
never the girl squad in real life that
we all wanted them to be and she sets
the record straight on those rumors of a
third movie saying she passed on playing
Samantha Jones again as soon as she was
offered the part lucky me to get any
kind of negative press about something
that I've been saying for almost a year
of know that that I'm demanding orang
diva specifically Sarah Jessica Parker
is that I think she could have been
nicer I really think she could have been
nicer I don't know what her issue is I
never thought I'd see this day you and
me both she also reveals the series
played a big part in her decision not to
have children I have 19 hour days on
this series I have weekends where I
finished at Saturday morning how could I
possibly continue to do that as for her
relationship with SJP and the gals these
days she says she can't even remember
the last time they spoke refresh my
memory how do we know each other again
they all have children and I'm 10 years
older I don't see them the common ground
that we had was the series and this
series is over
[Music]
you
[Music]